all of us have ancestors who were on the
planet much long before we were and I
feel like they prayed for this moment I
feel like there were so many people who
wanted it somehow it fell on me I don't
know why I got this opportunity and I
have to do everything I can to be a good
steward over you because you know what
to do with it I appreciate that and the
reason I feel that that is right is
because all of those are the people who
came before me taught me right so so
they pour it into me so that's what's
that's what's exciting for me for sure
your story is so powerful like I didn't
even I was reading all about you last
night I found out way more than I didn't
know and what does it feel like coming
from where you know the cards that were
handed to you in life and then ending up
on the water you know getting on the
walk of fame and star that's insane yeah
it feels like great faith right great
faith and a lot of work and it took a
lot of Prayer and my mother who's an
amazing woman I mean she dealt with all
kinds of horrible things I'm gonna bring
the mood down here but just abuse and
and things like that we had I did as
well and in the house in New Orleans at
the hand of my father but the thing
about it is my mother took me to church
she taught me about faith so I always
felt like I had somewhere to go in dark
times I could always pray I could always
believe a lot of people are getting away
from that but I'm telling you if you're
not too if you don't have teach your
kids something to help them they're
they'll turn to drugs they'll turn to
all kinds of things so for me I'm so
grateful my mother taught me about God
and faith and believing and holding on
because I wouldn't be here I wouldn't be
here belief and everything I think we
focus so much in the news on the
negativity of this world and on humanity
and that's what I want to do with this
show and I feel like that's what you do
through all your projects you really
inspire people and motivate people to be
better humans and there's always a
positive message that is like the goal
and war because I feel the light here so
it's good
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this